better be sky news thank you prime
minister
uh you just said the latest data is
flashing at us like
dashboard warnings in a passenger jet
and we must act
now and yet the only part of the country
today
put under these much stricter rules is
the liverpool
city region why is your rhetoric on this
outstripping the reality of the measures
you're actually
introducing and is it because you're
struggling to take regional leaders
with you and chris witte some areas like
bradford where i am now have been living
under restrictions
throughout the summer and into the
autumn
an analysis from the labour party last
week showed 19 out of 20 of those areas
put into local lockdowns have still not
come
out of them what is going on were they
the wrong restrictions
or are people not following the rules
well
first of all beth i mean just ready to
repeat what i would say it said to
to robert we want to take local
authorities uh with us
that obviously a local approach can be
immensely
valuable in uh enforcement there's a
local knowledge of the
uh of the the the area the places the
the
where the virus may be uh transmitted
the local activity in
enclosing down uh people who are blaking
breaking the
uh transparently breaking the rules uh
local uh
enforcement local tests and trades these
can be fantastically powerful
and we want to work with uh local
authorities to
to to deliver this and that's why uh
we we are were offering a
the deals and this and the solutions
that we are but you know just to repeat
the point i i made just now
if we uh if we can't get agreement uh
then clearly it is the duty of
of national government to take uh the
necessary action to
to protect the public and to protect
public health and and we will
and on bradford um specifically uh i
mean bradford
actually has shown superb leadership uh
the local authority has the directors of
public health have the local nhs have
in the way that they have tackled this
if they had not done so and consistently
working with the communities of bradford
uh we would be in a substantially worse
place than we are at the moment
in terms of wrong you know what all what
bradford is trying to do as
every uh town and city and area of the
country is trying to do
is to find this balance between keeping
the rates down
without doing unnecessary harm to
society uh to the economy and to all the
other things that in the long run have
major implications and you know i think
they have they've done
a large number of very imaginative
things yeah i see no evidence
that this is because the people of
bradford are flouting the rules i think
you know inevitably very occasionally
people will but the evidence
over the country as a whole is the great
majority of people intend to follow the
rules and do follow the rules
because the great majority of people
want this uh to protect their neighbours
to protect their family
and to improve the situation over uh
once we get through the winter which is
going to be difficult and everybody
knows that